hey guys this is the Reuben report I'm
Dave Rubin and I have two of my favorite
guests Jeana grad who has been on the
show many many times a crowd favorite
and Malcolm flesh knew who I was just
alerted you've never even been on the
show before we work together almost
every day we've we've hung out privately
and you've never been on the show before
what is this show again Virginia women
report virgin anyway I'm very excited
for the show so I thought we'd start
with something simple something that
everyone agrees on and something that
brings up a lot of good feelings and
positive will for mankind the Middle
East okay here we go so I am obviously
if you're following me on Twitter I am a
supporter of Israel I believe that the
Jewish people have a right to
self-determination just like every other
people including the Palestinian people
by the way and I've been hearing a lot
of crazy stuff and and misinformation
I've been sort of disappointed by people
on my side of the aisle because it seems
to me that Israel is the one country in
that part of the world that stands up
for all the things that we talk about
here all the time in terms of women's
rights and gay rights and economic
equality and science and medical
marijuana and all kinds of other stuff
but before we get into any of that and I
know the Nazis are already commenting on
YouTube love you guys I want to throw up
a map of the Middle East so I googled
map of the Middle East and here's what
came up so this is the first map of the
Middle East if you just google map of
the Middle East this is the first thing
that comes up now people seem to think
that the israeli-palestinian conflict is
the source of all the world's problems
and it's a huge thing that is causing
consternation all over the place now
what we are we really talking about guys
do you know where Israel is there
because that's the Middle East why it
doesn't say Israel on there do you know
where it might be on there by any chance
I happen to know where it is yeah it is
just a real little cashew sized sliver
right there on the coast right so that
little tiny thing between Syria and
Egypt now again this is the first map
when you google map in the Middle East
so then I wanted to zoom in on it so I
clicked it so then here we go with the
second one and then it actually zoomed
you out
okay so there so there it is now if you
look in the center of the thing a little
bit above Egypt to the right you can see
Israel and you can't even fit one letter
of the word Israel on the map now yes
that means Gaza and the West Bank are
even smaller than that but that's just
where I wanted to start to kind of show
everybody that when we're talking about
this area of the world that we're
talking about this tight ridiculously
tiny piece of land and maybe that's what
makes the real-estate all the more
valuable but I have a feeling that
people seem to think that it's this
massive ever-expanding country okay so I
want to just I'm gonna do just one
minute sort of Defense of Israel so you
know there was something called the the
partition plan the UN Partition Plan in
1947 and this is where the UN said we're
going to give two states to two people
the Jews said yes
the Arabs said no and then launched a
war and had there not been Israeli win
in the war there would have been a
second Holocaust right there this is
this is simply a fact then in 2005 so
I'm gonna just kind of jump all over
place and that's it so 2005 the Israelis
left Gaza they left altogether not one
Jew there again Hitler woulda loved the
place
there was no blockade by the way and but
then for two years they were Hamas would
won an election they ended up having a
bloody coup over Fatah so mokmou de bas
who's the president of the Palestinian
Authority he literally does not step
foot in Gaza cuz he's afraid he would
get killed so think about that they've
been negotiating over this land where
one of the guys negotiating is afraid to
step in part of the land that he's
supposed to control that's a bit of a
problem then Hamas took over they were
importing Rockets firing rockets and
then the blockade happened and by the
way the blockade is also happening from
Egypt in many cases much worse from
Egypt because they're not letting
anything in Israel is supplying Wi-Fi
and electricity and food and supplies in
blah blah blah okay so people are we
talk about about apartheid now apartheid
there are 12 members Israeli Arab
members of the Parliament in Israel
fully equal citizens there's also an
Israeli Supreme Court justice Israeli
Arab Supreme Court justice in Lebanon by
the way an Arab country Palestinians are
not
have about 60 jobs 60 white-collar jobs
including certain teaching jobs and
lawyers and things of that nature
Jordan which is anywhere from 50 to 80
percent Palestinian they're not allowed
to run for certain parts of office
because the king who's supposed to be
this great western guy they know he
knows that they'll just take over if he
lets them have equality they've also
been kept in Palestinians are kept in
refugee camps in Syria by the way 2,000
Palestinians were killed in Syria in the
last two years starved in the Yarmouk
refugee camp nobody really talks about
that you know and then everyone talks
about 1967 that this account this was
all about 1967 an occupation that
started in 1967 again a war that was
launched on Israel now maybe they
shouldn't have taken any land after that
and they should have said you know what
we can't take land it's not the right
thing to do I think that's a perfectly
legitimate argument that's not really
how any other country in the world works
but I think that's a certainly fine
argument but the idea that this started
in 1967 I'm pretty sure they didn't want
the Jews there before that so there's
that so basically what I think this is
really about is not whether the
Palestinians can have the state the
Israelis would give them a state or not
even give it's not even about give they
could have a state the world wants them
to have a state but I don't think it can
come on the heels of the death of the
Jewish state which is pretty much what
Hamas wants now I know there's gonna be
a zillion comments yelling at me for all
kinds of things I don't called all kinds
of mean words I hope you understand that
everything I said there was coming from
a place of I want peace I want there to
be two states if the Arab world would
jump into the world of modernity
modernity is that a word if they would
become modern and and care and do the
things that would lead to a civilized
state we could have peace in six months
Israel didn't leave Gaza so that they
could be back there nine years later
having to fight a war I mean that's just
not logical okay so how was that was
that pretty good I normally don't talk
that much here we go now is this ever
gonna stop Malcolm
well first thing I want to I didn't
realize until I looked at the map that
you showed that Israel is the Delaware
of the Middle East that you know poor
Delaware never gets its own you know
there's no room for it and Israel it's
the same thing
I you know I'm pretty sure that the
Middle East the whole
israeli-palestinian conflict is gonna be
solved but it's not gonna solve on this
show it's gonna be solved on Twitter
yeah that's my it's literally it's gonna
be solved because I I follow you on
Twitter and I monitor all your tweets
about it and I don't follow all the
conversations because there are only so
many hours in the day at night but I
assume there's plenty back-and-forth and
lately since the invasion of Gaza
there's been a tremendous uptick in the
number of comments you've made about how
great it is to be able to block people
on Twitter the bottom is the one thing
keeping me sane right now because
actually I'll have a debate with people
I'm trying not to have to be with
anonymous if you have an anonymous
Twitter profile with no name and just a
picture yeah often and I don't I don't
fight with eggs I did tweet that I will
not fight with an egg well I'm an
elitist what can I tell you but not I
wanna make this about Twitter so really
is is there any I know we can't I don't
want to get into the minutiae of every
ceasefire and everything that's
happening right now doesn't this thing
ever will this thing ever end
I fold disclosure I don't know that I
ever tried to hide this but I'm Jewish
culturally my points are Jewish
obviously your yeah and that's the thing
like and because I'm you know young
please let's just say I'm young yeah
okay perfect but you know like I don't
feel traditionally you know like I don't
I don't feel like I have this allegiance
because I'm supposed to have an
allegiance but I I do feel for the
Jewish people in general I mean we're
what less than 2% of the world
population we've been kicked out of
every country we've ever lived in the
world I like I'm so glad I'm not super
famous because we've taken totally out
of context but like if you were just
looking at the stats it would be easy to
say the world hates Jews yeah and that's
just the way it is it's not everyone
seems to love Jon Stewart you know what
it's funny you should say that too
because I lost a lot of respect for Jon
Stewart lately with especially when he
did the bit where you know he said
Israel and all these people started
yelling at him I don't know who the
people are that and maybe it's just
because they're not in my social circle
or even on social media but everyone
says Oh everyone's supporting Israel I
don't know anyone who's supporting
Israel outside of you know of
this conversation I don't know anyone
who who is actually in my opinion
looking at this in a fair way and I
understand and you know you you hear
people say well the Jews said after the
Holocaust never again okay on one hand
that means why would you put another
group of people in the same position
that you were in on the other hand it
means never again this is not going to
happen to us again so we're gonna have
to fight and we're gonna have to fight
harder this time
Jobar has a great line about that he
said you know everyone said in during
the Holocaust well why did the Jews just
go to the ovens and now they fight back
and ever and says well why do they fight
back so that's a perfect segue to my
second question is there any other
country or place on earth that is
accused of disproportionate force Colin
Powell had the Powell doctrine which
means that if you get into an armed
conflict you crush them to the point
where they give up immediately now
that's not what Israel's doing because
they're doing all this targeted stuff
and we know Hamas is literally hiding
rockets in UN schools this is a fact I
know people are gonna be happier but
it's a fact but is there what is
disproportionate what does that mean in
war has anyone the United States in Iraq
would qualify as disproportionate since
we shouldn't have done it in the first
place so but these are this is just
going to be if you are a supporter of
Israeli policy then you are not going to
think it's disproportionate and if you
are not then you were going to think
it's disproportionate so it just it just
this is I feel like a lot of it just
breaks down like it's your team like I'm
on the that's my team like a sports team
and whatever they do like I mean I'm
from Boston I grew up you know as a fan
of the Celtics and I actually found
myself rooting for Danny Ainge and he
was a horrible horrible person and a
horrible player he was not a bad player
but and but he was on my team so I had
root for him and then once he left he
was the biggest [ __ ] in the world a
really good point though can I just
speak of it I think you're so right I
think that people are so used to just
having their own conversations that
pipes up their own point and then the
other side is doing that and we're just
going to keep building this but if we
can just if somebody and people do this
a lot night I respect it and I'm happy
that it happens somebody who doesn't
believe what I believe makes a decent
point then it breaks that down a little
bit I'm like okay I see what you're
saying and that actually helps me
understand the other side here's what
I'm saying
never happened yes and that's exactly
why I prefaced this the way I did and
that I want this conversation to be a
real thing and I do believe peace is
possible it's gonna take it's gonna take
a lot of stuff but I don't think
everything is equal and we do have a
bizarre moral equivalence and people can
argue with me about that I terms of your
first question which I didn't really
answer oh and I have no sympathy for the
right-wing Israeli government I have no
sympathy for right-wing government's
anywhere generally I have no sympathy
for Hamas really and I think that the
part of the problem if you you talk
about is it gonna make you know it can
be solved in six months one of the real
issues is that the people of Israel and
the people the Palestinian people really
do detest each other and with with
legitimate legitimate grievances on both
sides and I mean if you go to I mean
it's we hear about how Hamas is their
textbooks are in there they're their
children shows are all about how the
Jews are the devil and so on and so
forth which is stupid and it's
counterproductive and that but then if
you go to say the the West Bank you go
to the checkpoints you see how the
Israeli soldiers treat the Palestinian
children and humiliate people are trying
to come into Israel and pointlessly so
that it's bred from childhood on both
sides and I don't believe that Hamas and
I don't believe the right-wing Israeli
government either them are all that
interested in peace unfortunately but
it's going to take the people of Israel
and the people of the Palestinian people
working independently and not often at
cross-purposes to their own governments
to achieve peace and do it on a personal
personal level which is incredibly
difficult and it's asking a lot it's
easy for me to say that over here but
that's that's the way I feel well I
think you made a couple extremely good
points there and that's the irony of if
you're defending Hamas right now you're
actually not defending the idea of a
Palestinian state because they left in
the first place so if you want them to
pull out of the West Bank which by the
way they've offered to do a who doll
mermaid an offer in two thousand ninety
percent of what the Palestinians say
they want Arafat just didn't respond
he made no counter proposal just didn't
respond it's in Bill Clinton's book I'm
sorry as I say a hoot Barak or yeah I
did so and then Omer the Prime Minister
in 2008 made an offer of 97 percent
including a refugee issue including
Jerusalem and there was no Abbas just
didn't show up to the meeting the next
day so there's a
litany of stuff we can't who was
pro-palestine and they will provide a
litany of their own of grievances
against that those offers which why they
weren't legitimate stones over and the
conversation no one gets all they want
so let's say the offer of 90% was
actually 80% which no one says that it's
like well with the Devils in the detail
what were you offering what you know
who's gonna control the water who's
gonna control the board I mean it's all
I mean these conversations they spiral
and it's it's the same as the
conversation about who's fault who's to
blame who started it yeah you know
that's so often is the conversation
that's why I didn't want to start with
that but that's the converse and at some
point in time I feel like we all have to
rise above that and say okay we're gonna
just put this to bed and we're gonna put
this to rest and we're not gonna quibble
over the history let's just move forward
and not argue about that and just argue
about what we can do in the future
because if we if we continue quibble
over the past it never ends
and that's why I didn't start their foot
say that yeah you make some such a great
point about how in general you know
we're we're constantly told that these
people hate each other it is to the the
marrow of their being it cannot change
and then you know you you talked about
how the Israeli soldiers have you know
humiliate the children and all this
stuff and and I I haven't seen anything
on that it's probably true I don't know
but it just got me the the word
propaganda just flashed through my head
I I get you know things about Israel I
get things about Palestine all the time
and I see these pictures of Israeli
soldiers helping Palestinian children or
helping older Palestinian men and they
say these are the pictures that are
never going to get circulated so we're
so far away and it's so tiny how do we
know what to believe right I mean I
don't think even on this network we
haven't done any stories about the the
hospital that Israel built right outside
of Gaza to bring in wounded people now
yes you could say they've attacked
hospitals there so okay we haven't done
any stories on the hospital that they
built for wounded Syrians this is a
country that they're technically at war
with so I know none of this stuff ever
ends anyway I hope we gave you a little
something there that shows a little
degree of tolerance and that we don't
all have to agree on everything but
maybe everyone could tone down the
rhetoric a little bit and kind of
challenge your preconceived notions as
I've tried to do my
self and now let's talk about comic
books for the comic book character
turned movie turned movie sequel well
guess what in the comic books he's gonna
be a chick that's right let's look at
Thor this is the Thor that you may know
right look at those muscles you like
that Gina don't you super into it
Malcolm you're into that those big pecs
and those I go I got more from bears you
go Muir bore of a bear guy so that is
that is Thor right there and let's look
at Thor's hammer of course Thor is known
for his hammer and on his hammer it says
whoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy shall possess the power of Thor
that's pretty good this is very old
manly right a lot of muscles I'm Ellie
but they are gonna change Thor to a
woman in the comic book we've got a
picture of the new lady Thor oh that's
right she is a handsome woman she she is
a feisty muscley chick and she looks
like she could do a lot of the things
that doors doing her we've got a quote
from the writer about this change this
is not she Thor this is not lady Thor
this is not Thor Rita this is Thor this
is the Thor of the Marvel Universe but
it's unlike any Thor we've ever seen
before so by the way just real quick
Chris Hemsworth will continue to play
Thor in the Marvel the Avengers movies
and I guess if they're gonna come out
with any others or sequels and things
like that but I think this is this is
kind of interesting when they make these
moves in comic books everyone freaks you
know you get a gay character and Archie
I thought Archie's stop being printed
you know 40 years ago but yeah exactly
but anytime they do anything in comics
and they've had a couple gay characters
and comic books comic books seem to get
a little ahead of the thing here so I
assume you have no problem with Thor
becoming a woman look man the only time
I ever heard of Thor in my life was when
I was little watching adventures in
babysitting that's the first time the
Thor character ever came
I'm not a comic book person I don't give
a [ __ ] however I did find a great meme
if I may share it with you this is great
Disney owns Marvel Marvel owns Thor Thor
is the son of a king Thor is now female
that means Thor is now a Disney Princess
and she but I mean I know I made a joke
about her you know gigantism but you
know she looks like a really powerful
chick and you know I there's we've
actually done stories on TYT about one
of the characters that they change to
african-american and people went insane
so I can't imagine the reaction of this
is gonna be any different but she looks
like a good character you know I mean
she's got the the gigantic boobs and we
know she's female but she looks powerful
she looks strong she looks badass
Malcolm I know you're a traditionalist
you have major problems with this well I
mean to me I don't know the in follows
Thor knows too much so I did it I looked
up Thor on Wikipedia to find out and
what I know about Thor is he has long
flowing golden locks he apparently is
associated with fertility and he's
legendary for fighting a giant snake and
that doesn't sound like a woman to me
that sound like a woman oh my god you're
right no I think that this is it's
interesting I it seems like the comic
books it's a marketing ploy obviously
they want to sell some comic books
whatever but I feel like comic books say
they trail the popular opinion I mean
who a gay character can you believe it I
mean wow that's shocking and and now
what Captain America is african-american
and so I feel like it's just whatever is
becoming accepted you know it gains more
widespread acceptance and then the comic
books you know they follow along so so
we've got a female Thor black Captain
America and a gay character on an Archie
and ten years from now we'll have like a
trans thora trapped in Captain America
will be a Muslim yeah and the Fantastic
Four will all be polyamorous I think
what I assume that people who are super
traditionalist when it comes to comics
don't like is that they're changing
characters already in progress they're
not creating a new powerful woman
they're saying oh that dude he's a chick
now just get on board and that's really
should we be okay with those people that
are just saying this is about the lore
of the thing if the next star wars if
they magically made
really makes evader well you gotta move
I guess you could have you could have an
evil female gender but if you suddenly
if Luke Skywalker for the next one was
suddenly a woman he had a sex change in
the 30 years till the next one people
might be would be upset if anybody
involved in Star Wars did something to
ruin the franchise that would be there
there are people who'd not like thank
God that'll never have alright final
thought on this can you do anything
creatively without it being a political
statement can anyone do anything can a
comedian say anything can an artist
paint anything can a comic book without
everyone jumping on the political like
it's someone maybe this guy was just
like I'm just gonna do this I'm not
putting a lot of thought into it I'm you
just can't write I loved his statement
this is a thaw Reena
this isn't lady Thor this is Thor like
this it's not because it it's not like
okay she's Thor but working it like like
we're gonna Disney Princess if I her no
it's just the character and people hate
that [ __ ] but they're the same people
that need to be sending those people a
muffin basket because then we'd have
nothing to talk about say that even
asking that question is a political
statement
that's why we've never had you on the
show for by just saying can't you do
anything without it being taken as a
political statement that you know no the
New York Post is reporting that out of
the 37,000 911 workers
2,500 of them have cancer so we've got
somewhere info for you on this last year
1140 cases of cancer were reported among
ground zero responders and rescuers but
the number now has grown to over 2500
911 workers suffer from cancers at a
much greater rate than the general
population specifically lung cancer
prostate cancer thyroid cancer and
leukemia
so far the B CF which is the victim
compensation fund has awarded 115 cancer
patients with a total of fifty point
five million in sums ranging from four
hundred thousand to four point 1 million
so you know we when you think about 911
obviously you think about the thousands
of people that died you think about the
families that have to live with the
grief that kind of stuff and the
responder is sort of like
you know people that fight wars across
the world they come home and then we
kind of forget about them
shouldn't we be hearing a lot more about
this yes but why would they put these
people in the spotlight because it's a
it just makes everyone and I'm not
saying I feel this way I'm saying this
is why I think that we don't it makes it
brings up a terrible memory in our very
recent history and makes people feel bad
because they feel powerless and it
doesn't shine I mean I don't really know
how this would be the government's fault
I mean I was I was there I was a few
blocks up in a horrible horrible day
but people running into danger knew that
there are risks running into danger so
everyone feels so powerless I mean and
and as far as cancers go these are
pretty much the worst prostate cancer
thyroid cancer these are the very very
low rate of survival so I I just don't
know what I don't necessarily know what
the point is and I don't mean it like
that
I just I don't know how it benefits
people because there's nothing we can do
except what give them money right so
right so we're giving them money but of
course we could probably give them
better medical care and there's all kind
of things that we probably can do that
have nothing to do with money
just one little antidotal thing I was in
New York City on 9/11 and I lived on
90th and 1st which if you know anything
about New York City that's pretty far
yeah that's pretty far I lived on the
far upper east side literally about
three hours after the planes hit you
could smell the burning debris you could
smell and there was stuff in the air
which went on for days but I mean that
so I'm talking about something that was
extremely far from where it happened so
these people who were right in the thick
of it sadly none of this is surprising
why why don't we do better for these
people
well I think it's sort of like the VA
scandal where we want these people to we
doubt them and we say we appreciate your
service everything but we're gonna
totally [ __ ] you over and then we're
gonna ignore him and forget you forget
about you and I'm not saying we have
done that entirely but for the most part
that's we do and I one thing that I
would like whenever we talk about the
Ground Zero responders and the cancer
rates on it is to remind people that the
Bush administration EPA chief christie
todd whitman said three days after the
attacks that the air is perfectly safe
that we have evidence and we know the
air is perfectly safe
don't worry about
go right ahead and that in two years
later the EPA inspector general came out
with a report saying she had no basis
for saying that and she was sued and
then and in 2006 I have there that the
US District Judge Deborah batts allowed
a lawsuit against we're gonna proceed
and called Whitman's actions conscience
shocking but later on that finding was
overturned on appeal and Whitman could
not be was not held liable for her
comment so she faced no consequences and
it so it's it's not a scandal but it's
also the too-big-to-fail sort of like
we're gonna protect the upper the the
elites they're not going to face any
consequences for this that's that's it
feels like in terms of a lot of the
military well it's not my kid I you know
I I can buy him out of this situation
but you people you're fine just go and
that's and I don't know all the legal
jargon I don't know any of the legal
jargon outside of watching a few CSIS
but when you say that about Christy Todd
Whitman all I think I was like shouldn't
she be held for like manslaughter she
should be ashamed to show her face I
think I mean that's it's it's
unconscionable what she did and but she
faces no consequence no social no
political consequences she is I'm sure
gets fifteen twenty thousand dollars for
speeches or she towards the country I
mean I don't know what she's doing she's
in some think-tank but I mean it isn't
this is the type of thing that we where
President Obama we were giving him a lot
of crap last week about fundraising for
three days in the middle of this whole
everything with the Middle East and
Russia and Ukraine and all that isn't
this one of these things where maybe he
could say you know what for the next
three days I'm gonna fundraise for these
people he raised around six million for
the DNC last week he could just as
easily raise six million for these
people so this is just pot like this is
just the worst kind of like that also
sends the wrong message like we did like
we have to do special things for them
this should be built in well we should
have to do special things for them no we
should be built into the federal
government however we take care of these
people but that didn't happen it's been
thirteen years so now is the time for
somebody to stand up and do something
Jon Stewart's job isn't it but the other
thing is that this is also the
consequence of the Bush administration
failure to stop the attacks and I mean
the the all people dying in their Iraq
now the VA scandal the first responders
all the soldiers who died in Iraq it's
all because they did
you could argue it's because it's a
consequence of them ignoring the PDB in
August 6 2001 saying that people are
thinking about you know flying planes
into buildings
yeah and it's it's perfect you're not
gonna believe this folks but the rich
are getting richer and the poor are
getting poorer
that's right a new study came out from
the Russell Sage Foundation and they
found out some pretty interesting stuff
let's take a look between 2003 and 2013
the average household's net worth
adjusted for inflation dropped by 36% in
10 years from about 87,000 to about
56,000 in the same time frame the
wealthiest 5% of the households increase
their net worth by 14% now we've got a
24% gap right there alone in New York
there are 30 about 390,000 New Yorkers
worth more than a million which means
that one out of every 21 residents of
the city is a millionaire I guess that's
why I left New York I'm not millionaire
all right now we talk about income
inequality all the time here and if we
know it's getting worse but is this
another one of these issues where it
just keeps getting worse because the
whole system is rigged and we just don't
like this just we don't know how to dig
ourselves out of it well I think for me
I don't know why and I'm nowhere near a
part of being a millionaire a
billionaire or even a thousand-aire
these days but I do feel like it's
important to say that I don't blame most
of these millionaires for being
millionaires they got into you know good
you know they they found their niche
they made it work a free economy sounds
great and that's not the problem I don't
think that's the problem let people make
their money but now that that's
happening and on the other side of it I
don't even know how related they are in
all the cases but it said like you know
the average income was like 87,000 now
it's 55 but now the cost of going to
college is more expensive your grocery
baskets gonna be half full with the same
that it would have been five years ago
with a you know full cart of groceries
so that's the thing I don't blame them
but I'm certainly angry yeah well every
time we talk about this I always say I
don't begrudge anyone success I do agree
with you and also to have a million
dollars you can live in Westchester near
and work in New York City and have a
million dollars and really not be
there's a difference between ultra rich
and being upper-middle-class being a
millionaire used to mean something you
know nowadays when I'm in New York I
can't even step out of my limo without
bumping into a dozen other millionaires
it's unconscionable yeah I want people
to you're rich
I want you to stand apart millionaire
pool you can't swing your sable without
getting another millionaire I understand
yeah it's it's I agree it's shocking and
horrifying that there are so many
millionaires when we should really be
talking about billionaires no I mean
you're both is where you're both saying
I don't forget people their success and
I don't either but the problem is that
we have a system that is rigged against
poor people to keep the poor people poor
and to keep rich people rich and they're
the ones who are rigging the system it's
not really the millionaire so because
you're a millionaire it may not even put
you in the top
it probably puts you in the top 1% but
it doesn't put you it doesn't put you in
the mean a lot of that might be you own
a home that is worth you know $700,000
you got $4,000 in the bank which is
obviously comfortable but it's not but
it's not Daddy Warbucks but and that's
what so when we've done this and we've
talked about the 1% what I always try to
say is what we really should be talking
about is the point 1 percent because the
one or the point oh one percent because
these are the people with really the
hundreds of millions if not the billion
right and and I I think I've just we've
heard this topic a lot we've talked
about this topic lot as a society and I
just had this like urge to like get out
in front of it and say that because I
think people always come back and go you
just don't appreciate people who work
hard that is not what I think anyone is
trying to say yeah so okay so we're all
you weren't way too [ __ ] hard as my
producer at MIT 114 it's good to know
so okay so we talk about that all the
time so I guess the real issues all
right so let's move the the rich people
are okay
so let's talk about those poor people so
their income down ten percent in only
ten years is there so who do we blame
okay I get it's a system but it seems to
me I don't know that the Democrats have
been any better
I could said nobody's good nope nobody
is good everyone's taking money from
Goldman Sachs Hillary Clinton included
you know she just stepped in by the way
this week george w bush couldn't do a
speech for 250,000 so hillary clinton's
doing they were incredible
who's responsible for paying george w
bush $200,000 for his speech i mean
somebody offered what's the return on
that well i mean i know i can't wait to
hear his insights he's really gonna i
mean maybe he'll talk about the
political system scene right now he
really got a lot to say about that
yeah so nobody is that the answer that
both both both of the parties well i
think the question is at what point in
time do people become so squeezed that
they actually go and get grab the
torches and pitchforks because that's
what like Nick Hanauer is a
multi-billion every multi-millionaire
Seattle you know made money in the tech
industry and he's talked about this
he supports raising the minimum wage and
doing more for health care and so on and
so forth because he's concerned like
he's like we need to worry about this
you know the gates you know they're not
there's no way our gated communities are
secure enough I've seen there have you
seen the security guards who work there
they're just hoping that the cost of
pitchforks and torches Rises so I don't
they think that don't they see how this
affects everybody and it can affect
everyone in a positive way a society
that just has the top people in the
bottom people can't stand it's like
they've never heard the phrase a high
tide raises many boats so if you're
taking care of your people your people
will take care of you yeah and that's
why we need a strong middle class which
we did have at one time in this country
and who knows maybe one day we will get
back have you heard about Detroit
Michigan it is going to hell in a
handbasket we have talked about this a
little bit before but but Detroit is
literally cutting off water to its
residents who can't afford to pay their
water bills and now I know some people
that will have you can't afford water
that is you're gonna have water really
okay yeah that's right nearly 300,000
people may soon have their water turned
off some people have had the water
turned off already
15,000 have had their water shut down
and the water company is not slowing but
PETA which is People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals they want to lend a
hand by agreeing to pay the late water
bills for 10 Detroit families and what's
the catch well you just have to eat
vegan yeah that's right
we've got a quote from the PETA blog
the last thing the people who are
struggling need is increased healthcare
cost by accepting our offer to go vegan
not only will families be getting an
immediate financial boost and helping
animals if they stick with it
they'll also lower their risk of obesity
heart disease cancer diabetes and
strokes okay so they're trying to do
something nice now this is only ten
they're only doing this for ten families
now there are literally thousands and
thousands of people that are having
their water ten but I guess they're
trying to do something nice here but by
the nature of this being ten families
isn't it fair to say this is far more of
a publicity stunt than actual work to
get these people to have their water
back on that doesn't sound like the PETA
I know that they would be oh yes I mean
of course the publicity stunt but
realistically and I don't know if
anybody's even going to take them up on
it it seems like one of the challenge I
mean it's hard enough to get like if you
live in a inner city of Detroit those
are food we're called food deserts and
it's hard enough to only have grocery
stores and something that they have to
shop at bodega isn't alike and I haven't
been to Detroit so I don't know what
Detroit is like specifically one vegan
basket to get them started Malcolm I'm
like where are they gonna where they're
gonna eat this vegan but realistically
it's a big glass of water to choke down
that tofu it could be very drunk I'm not
gonna badmouth veganism because you're
we have there there are people in this
part of this network very unhappy with
yeah and but yes it's a publicity stunt
for PETA but realistically it's also a
publicity stunt to draw attention to the
fact of what's going on in Detroit with
these people if not for PETA we wouldn't
be talking about this probably so while
you can accuse them of you know using
whatever tactics they can take advantage
bandwagon at least we're talking about
it and it's raising awareness about that
issue and I think we should also
recognize that the residents of Detroit
while they are having their water cut
off the businesses of Detroit are not
having their water cut off even though
they are they owe Detroit the city of
Detroit like or the water company five
million dollars or more and they do not
face because they can they can fight it
legally but poor people have no capacity
to fight this legally so they're the
ones who get screwed over so that being
said should we cut Peter some slack here
it seems like kinda just a publicity
stuff but they're sorta
I think this is deplorable I think this
is so demeaning
this is a way of I mean III think I
think a lot of us think that water is a
basic human right you gotta have water
you can survive for a while without
eating I can't but you can survive way
less than what we're first of all kind
of always forget my note and I I get
Peter's vibe I support a lot of things
they do I'm happy for the most part that
they exist but I think this is so
degrading to the people of Detroit to
say we'll help you with your water bill
which for an organization like PETA
isn't a lot of money if you you know
dance clown dance like do what we want
you to do and try and eat vegan like
[ __ ] you it's not about you and your
agenda it's about these people not
having water I think it's I think it's
it's humiliating to the people who take
them up on it and I think they're
totally demeaning and degrading the
people of Detroit you know what I was
sort of in between the two you but by
the time you finish that sentence I'm
with you on this it reminds me of these
people like in New York City when there
are homeless people asking for money and
I had a friend who would be walking a
comic that I used to know and we'd be
walking down a street in Times Square
they'd be all these homeless people and
he'd be like I only give homeless people
that if they do something like I want
them to do something you know what I
mean like sing a song or do a card trick
or something like that but because then
they're doing something otherwise I'm
just giving them something and I think
that that goes your point what do you
guys make the fact that we're just
watching a city in our country literally
fall apart I have been to Detroit and
there are parts of Detroit that are
really nice the the baseball stadium is
really nice the publicly funded GM
Renaissance Center which is where the
original Total Recall is from really
nice it's great it's really cool so
there's some stuff but if you go outside
of that I mean it almost looks like a
war zone there are houses just decimated
there are areas that are completely gone
we're watching this happen in America
it's never on the knees yeah the city of
Detroit is disintegrating and it's this
I mean it relates to the other topic we
did with the income inequality and the
collapse of the middle class in America
collapse of unions I mean there's you
know the but it's it didn't just happen
I know there are people who say oh that
they blame the residents of Detroit it
didn't just happen these were policies
that were pursued and this is the
logical outcome of those policies and
there are certain people who gain from
this and there are others who
and the people who gained from it have
all the political influence on people
who don't do not and I also think that
there are gimmicks there are like these
weird little kind of dare I use this
word fun ways to get attention on
Detroit I know that a while ago they
were auctioning off houses for like next
to nothing beautiful houses live here
come put money back into the community
that's awesome that's an amazing
publicity stunt and I hope it worked but
this this is adding insult to injury
because either we're not talking about
how the city has been destroyed when
this city was the backbone of how
America was America I mean like people
you know people talk about well you know
my grandfather worked for GM for many
years and you know he had a great
retirement house and we had a you know
all this stuff
they have nothing now and then to add
insult to injury saying if if you if you
tell us a joke or juggle we'll give you
you know 100 bucks for your water it's
horrible great advances in the quality
of vegan food by the way also I was a
vegetarian for 13 years I regret every
day of it Turkey's Deputy Prime Minister
recently had some interesting things to
say about the Turks saying that they had
quote abandoned their values and is
pleading with people to rediscover the
Koran but then he made some interesting
comments about women chastity is so
important it is not only a name it is an
ornament for both women and men she will
have justice man will have it too he
will not be a womanizer he will be bound
to his wife he will love his children
the woman will know what is Haram and
what is not Haram
she will not laugh in public she will
not be inviting in her attitudes and
will protect her chaste Ness now the
reason I thought this was kind of
interesting is because Turkey sorta in
between worlds right now where they are
very secular and that seems to be where
most Turks want to go and they have a
prime minister who's going more in the
other direction but I thought that quote
was really interesting too because he's
sort of saying you know a man has to
kind of step up and do the right thing
but then it veers in
women shouldn't laugh women are allowed
to laugh are they not mouthing I don't
know this guy doesn't seem like a barrel
of laughs
that's that reads like the worst
match.com profile like what he's looking
for
no no but you know our dads chastity if
we need to keep the the women of Turkey
not laughing in public Jay Leno is
available no no no no yeah this guy
sounds like a lot of fun and it it
sounds like um we need to send Jack
Yager over there to ten still a little
low more agnosticism and and fun in the
Turkish state he left and everything
goes to pot you know what speaking of
the power of jakey where he went to
Turkey a couple weeks ago wild turkey
had YouTube shut down by their prime
minister by the time jenk left Turk
YouTube was back up so I'm just saying
that he can do something also huge jenna
Marbles fans just one correction in the
quote when he said chastity is is
important what he means is suppressing
half of the population is important yeah
I mean what does this have anything else
to do with you know you can you can only
hide behind religion so much until it
gets so ridiculous that people are gonna
go shut up you don't even nothing you
say makes any sense yeah I laugh like
Ethel Merman I would they block me way
and throw away the key
I wouldn't you have a great laugh yeah
you would be in a lot of trouble as soon
as one of you says something funny
you're gonna hear it yeah well when does
this when when do we stop taking these
things seriously yes so that's partly so
I almost didn't do this story because we
hear about these things all the time and
look we talked about Saudi Arabia all
the time which is our great ally in the
Gulf where women can't drive nor vote
they are right they are actually allowed
to be going to be allowed to vote sooner
than they can drive so they just won't
be able to drive to the polling stations
but do we have any right to tell any
country what to do when it comes to any
of this in his defense the women drivers
think I'm kind of on board with I gotta
be honest no I'm kidding I'm kidding
yeah it's interesting because you know
when you talk about morality and like
this is I assume it's just a distraction
this guy is trying to distract from the
other problems of corruption and that is
that their government is accused of and
it seems like it's the it's a fallback
position it's something that they can go
to quickly and distract much like if
you're Saudi Arabia and you want to talk
you want to distract people from your
own problems and we don't want to get
people talking about how the women can't
drive you're like those Israelis those
sons of [ __ ]
those Jews how they treat the
Palestinians why we know don't but
ignore the way we treat the Filipinos
who come here to build our stadium so on
and so forth but so what was your
question I think you whatever my
question was I think you do we have the
right do we have a right because you
know we do all these things with these
countries Turkey obviously is an ally of
ours Saudi Arabia is an ally of ours for
better or worse so do we have what maybe
do we need tiered allies like you're in
the a group you know in Canada well we
do but maybe we need to say it more
should we be say because the women thing
like this is half the world isn't it
more than half the world there are more
women than messages when we criticize a
country like Turkey yeah and we make fun
and we ridicule this guy which we he
rightfully deserves ridicule but doesn't
that empower him to say you know those
the u.s. the you know the evil Americans
are criticizing our culture and it feeds
into what he's trying to accomplish and
actually does him a favor yeah I don't
know it's a tough call because it's how
are you not going to ridicule this guy I
just I can't get on board with that I
mean and that's the thing it's like
should we go and invade them over this
no we can't and we shouldn't but when it
comes to terms of you know like you said
being an ally doing business how do you
how do you do this and feel good about
yourself as a government when these
other governments are so oppressive you
know it's like well it's not my mom it's
not my sister it's not my wife well it's
somebody else's and if she's into it
she's been brainwashed I mean that's all
there is to it speaking of brainwashing
I hope you enjoyed the show today this
was one of my favorite shows this was a
meaty show I hope you laughed a little
bit maybe learned it's a little
something and maybe got a little more
tolerance
something comment down below like all
that good stuff of course follow Gina
and Malcolm on the Twitter their
Twitter's are right down below and we'll
do this again next week thanks